thank you so much for joining today or
this evening
depending on where you're calling from
this is jeremy schieffen at khan academy
and i'm so excited they're joining with
us because if anything
at khan academy 2020 has been the year
of the tablet
we've given away by my calculation at
least 50 tablets
over the course of the year in response
to questions like how does salcon make
those videos how can i make my own
videos
and that's why i'm so excited about
tonight's session because now you're
going to learn from the experts
themselves
first of all we are so lucky to have
stacy with us um stacy is a math teacher
and director of innovation educational
technology
at the bullis school in maryland and one
of the things that really impresses me
is not only does she wear multiple hats
at school but she's also the author of
tech with heart
which is an amazing book on how to use
tech in your classroom
not just to break your students down
into bits and bytes but to actually
empower them to lift them up
and i think in 2020 you can't imagine a
better lesson than how to use technology
in a more holistic way so
check out tech with heart would make a
great stocking stuffer and then also i
have to give a huge shout out
to the wacom team um if you're familiar
with wacom the brand
they are the world's leader in
handwriting tablets
so whether you use it for design or for
teaching there's these really powerful
tools
to bring your teaching style and your
pedagogy into the digital world
and in fact sal khan himself has been
using their tablets for a decade at this
point
and still using them to make videos at
this very moment so a huge shout out to
the wacom team
and especially because wacom has been
generous enough to give away
five more tablets to lucky attendees
tonight and you'll be notified
automatically
just for being in attendance if you're
one of those lucky five
and then in addition even if you're not
selected to win a tablet
wacom is giving an exclusive discount
code just to attendees of the session
that stacey will unveil at the very end
of the presentation now all that being
said
i would be remiss in 2020 on a webinar
not to mention that number one this is
being recorded
so you'll get all those goodies in your
email right afterwards
including a pdf of the handouts and all
the links that we talked about
and then of course because we're
educators um all in all we want to make
sure the session is really interactive
so ask questions at any point using the
questions tab and stacey will take a ton
of those questions at the end of the
session
so without further ado let me turn it
over to stacy to tell you all about how
you can use
tablets in your own classroom to make
2021 even more effective
over to you stacy thank you so much
i'm so excited to be with you all this
evening
or whatever time it is over on your end
um so i'm going to be sharing
some ways that you can use the tablet
um i have been using a wacom tablet
myself uh for years now
i think i got my first one in 2013. and
what i love about these tablets is that
it's the same tablet that i was using in
2013
i'm still able to use today so i'm going
to showcase some of their newer products
um it has worked for me over the years
and it's a way
of allowing me to handwrite on anything
and as a math teacher i need that
um so in addition to my role in really
working as a
coach with us with teachers at my school
and helping them onboard the tech that
will work best for their classroom i'm
also
an ap calculus teacher so i've taught a
number of classes over the year but in
the
past several years i've taught ap
calculus a b
i also taught a purely online version of
ap calculus a b
for a number of years and i am a flipped
classroom teacher
so i'll get into a lot of how i started
exploring
the tablets and how i'm using them now
and hopefully some easy ways to help you
get started
if you are on twitter i would love to
connect with you
my twitter hashtag is or my twitter
handle
is at buddyxo um so if you are there
please connect with me and if you have
any questions at all i'm so happy
to follow up um and answer as many as i
can
i do have a contact form on my blog so
now that we're done with that little
intro let's go ahead
and um let me start off with some of the
things i hope to
achieve today first of all how to get
started
with a whiteboard application then
um how to use the scratch pad in khan
academy
then we'll talk more about how to ink up
slides and make screencasts of your own
and then as jeremy said we will have
some time for q and
a so before we get started i'm gonna
just put a question out to you what
subject do you teach and
what grade levels do you teach
can go ahead and type that in
okay we've got the poll on your screen
so feel free to start answering right
there
about a third of the 500 or so educators
across the country have answered
we're up to about two-thirds now and it
looks like there are a lot of educators
who are following in your footsteps
stacy
because as we close the poll and share
the results you can see that a plurality
are math educators
awesome hopefully
that's right but also also a nice
diversity of educators across the
content spectrum
let's do the same for grade level now so
elementary all the way to high
maybe even beyond or before
and it's looking like a little bit of a
horse race between middle and high
school
and we'll go ahead and share that and
looks like a lot of high school
educators again
um your tribe is here in forest tonight
stacey so a lot of high school math
educators have joined us
all right
we'll have some fun tonight
so this is me um back in the day let me
go back into present
um this is me back in the day when i
started flipping my classroom this was
back
in 2010 and um
what i had here was a tablet pc actually
so this is how i got started
making my videos i had a microphone that
i got and i was using my tablet pc
which is what we had through our school
that was kind of how i got interested
in the first place i said hey i got this
technology in my hands let me start
making some screencasts for my students
especially when i started ap
calculus teaching you know how much
content there is to get through not
enough time to get through it
so i wanted a way to offload that very
teacher directed
lecture to video and i started using my
tablet pc to do that
however i am a mac user um and
this tablet pc wasn't my preference so
um when i learned about wacom then i had
my solution because
i could plug the tablet into my mac
and i still had the pen and the
handwriting
and i've been happily using that
solution
ever since so um there are two main
types
of wacom devices there is the
slate style like this one in the left so
this is
a blank slate and you can write
just looking up at the screen is what
you would have to do there
so that you're not seeing what you're
writing actually you're looking up at
the screen to see
what you're writing and then there's
also the display style tablets
like this one where you actually either
mirror your screen
or you use it as a second display just
like if you had another
monitor attached so
that is really amazing especially in
remote learning i think we've all
learned that we need two monitors
and so this can be a simple way to have
two monitors available to you or two
screens available
to you so i um really recommend the
wacom intuos there are different
styles of it but i like the one this is
the small one that i have it's a small
style but it is bluetooth and i love
that because it's wireless and i can
move it around
easy to carry with me um it when we are
in the actual classroom and we're able
to move around
this is a great device to have throw it
in your bag
and then the wacom one is what i
actually make
my flipped classrooms video clip
classroom videos with
nowadays you do have to plug it in so it
is much larger i have it right here i
don't have it plugged in
because i didn't want another screen
going right now
but um this is really great because i
can have it
to write out all of my lessons
make my screen recordings and it feels
so natural
it really feels like writing on paper
the quality of this tablet is amazing um
and i recommend the welcome one because
it's the lowest price point
for a screen display style
tablet that wacom offers and it's met
all of my needs as a math teacher
100 and it feels so so nice
to write on so those are the two style
of tablets i just wanted
to throw those out there for some
background and then i'm going to
pose one more question to you right now
do you currently have a writing tablet
so i think there's a poll that you can
answer on this one
and it looks like we're up to about
almost 90 percent of the votes here
stacy
um it looks like about as you can see
here on the screen
about a third of teachers have that
writing tablet already
but the majority do not so just a little
good background to go on
awesome so hopefully that some of that
background was helpful
in helping you understand the different
styles of tablets that are available and
which one you might
want to purchase going forward if you
really just are
looking to get get started with the most
affordable option
and the most portable option that is the
intuos
style tablet and again there's a
bluetooth version of that which is what
i really like because i can just be
using it just click a button
no wires needed and i can move around
and it's wireless
um again the wacom one i love
it for making my classroom videos it
does need to be plugged in so i just
like to mention that because
i think it's important to weigh the
options do you need portability
or are you gonna be making videos all
the time
um in which case i think the wacom one
is really worth
the investment that's what i use um most
of my time and i just love it
all right
so let's continue on
and start with some of the basics
so i wish that i could just tell you
hey this is what i recommend this is
what you should do
but the reality is we are all
at different schools that use different
technologies that have different
subscriptions but also we're at google
schools we are at microsoft schools we
are at google meet schools we
are at zoom schools right now and so i
am going to present again a variety of
options ones that i would most recommend
depending on which of those camps you
fall into
so if you are using google everything
already
if you're using google meet um even if
you're using
zoom and your school is a google school
i think
google jamboard is the simplest
whiteboarding option
that i can possibly offer you there is a
video of how the google meet integration
with the
jamboard whiteboard works if you haven't
used that before
and again these resources are available
after and i put a little play button so
that you can know
that you can watch this video afterwards
if you want to review it i'm
trying to load you up with some
resources to really help you out
but i'm going to show you just a basic
demo and you can get started by just
going to your google
drive pressing the new button go into
more and then
using a google jamboard and that's how
you start up a new whiteboard or
if you're in a google me you'll see that
option right when you click the three
dots
so let me show you what a jamboard looks
like it is super simple super basic
but it is collaborative or it can be
just more instructional so
like anything else in google you can
share this and make everybody else
an editor or you can share it with view
only permissions if everybody else is an
editor it's real time collaboration
amazing right so there
is a pen tool right here and again the
options with this one are very very
simple you only have
a couple pallets of color here you do
have different
pen thicknesses uh you have a marker you
have a highlighter
uh you have more of a brush tool and so
you know you can just
very simply get to writing if you want
to write
you can also pull in an image so
sometimes i like to use this
to say you know you have a question that
you want
take a snapshot of the question pull it
into here
and then just use your tablet and write
that's basically it um you can present
during class with this
also there's this nice laser pointer so
it's easier for students to follow
what you are writing and you can more
easily point
uh there's a sticky note that you can
have and then from a
um people who need some shapes there's
some basic shapes here available too
so this i think is one of the simplest
options available
it is automatically built into google me
if you're using that or if you're using
google drive
um sorry if you're a google school then
this will save to your google drive
so that's the nice ability there too and
you can share
lastly you can always export this save
this as a pdf
afterwards so that you can share these
as lesson notes if you can't get
everything on one slide
you can make multiple pages just like
that um and so
those are the very very basics of
getting started with this
and there's also the ability to um have
some grid paper
background also
so let me go ahead and move into the
next
option which um since i was on google
schools
this one is really i feel like if you
are a
google school that is already a cami
user if you
are using cami or if your school has a
site license to cami
i really recommend checking that tool
out
if you've not heard about it before it's
not this
it's not the absolute thing that you
need right now i want you to pick which
one
is going to fit your needs the best but
what cami is it's integrated again with
google drive
but it also can be kind of just a
whiteboarding tool because there are
these amazing pen tools built right in
to cami um this is a chrome extension
by the way you can get it so you can
open any of your google drive files
with cami you can also just go to cami
on the web
and you can write so again i can just
write and talk um there's so many more
features available in the cami
i could do a whole webinar on cami to be
honest
there is even the ability to make your
whole screen capture right here in cami
if you have a paid version
but what i like to show here is just
like this for example
was um i was just showing how students
can kind of
upload work that they were stuck on and
then
they can pull it all into a document and
then i can use the pen tools
like i used right here to guide to say
where they went wrong for example
we can discuss errors as a class
so again this is one of the really nice
a whiteboarding tool you can add extra
pages as you go
when you want to add more pages again if
you need
lined paper you can have that if you
need grid paper you can have that
if you want a music sheet you can even
add that
um so if you are using cami already
and you haven't thought about using it
as kind of a white boarding tool
that's going to be my recommendation to
you
and that's really again if you're a
google school because that's tied with
google
so let's move on from google schools um
and if you are using
zoom zoom has a whiteboard built
right in so i have a demo
here um again if you want to watch this
after the fact you can just press play
and watch how to get started with the
tool but it is one of the simplest
options available and what's more in
zoom you can actually write
anywhere on your screen so it doesn't
have to
just be a whiteboard that you're writing
on you can
ink up anything using the annotation
tools
that are in zoom so if you haven't used
that before
and if you're using zoom then again you
use your wacom tablet now you have an
actual pen and you can be handwriting
instead of you know just using your
mouse which is very difficult
so that zoom again if you're using that
i would definitely check out this video
if you're not already
final whiteboarding tool that i'm going
to showcase
is if you want something that's not tied
to google and not tied to zoom
but is very simple to get started with i
like awe
app which is um for a
right here a web whiteboard and i'm just
using it for free so you do get
advertisements that is the only downside
to this
um but otherwise it can be a
collaborative board so i can invite
other people to it so it can be
collaborative or i can just be doing my
screen share
and writing there are some more options
in this one so this is actually a tool
that i use
quite often um because it's simple
but also there's a little bit more
functionality so i can
upload a picture or even a pdf i
usually just would upload like a picture
of a question
that i want to solve as a class and then
i can choose from more of a variety of
color palettes right here or you can
choose from the color wheel so you can
get more colors right there available to
you
there's an undo button very easily um
and then again you can be
writing as you're talking you have the
eraser tool
and this one gives you a variety of
options here where like you can change
the size of the eraser
um you can also like erase the whole
thing in one click which makes it a
little bit easier to use than just
erasing little bit by little bit
especially when you're doing like a
whole lesson it's i know it sounds minor
but it can be very helpful
again you have some shape tools and then
you have some text
uh what i like about this app too is
that as you're writing
so you know you can be doing a problem
um let me change the color like over
here
and then what you can do
is you can actually zoom in and out
and you can write on different parts of
the board so i can be
zooming out i can move my
right over here too then i can move my
whole
board over so i just have this is kind
of like
a huge canvas that i can have and i can
keep
writing and if i want to see everything
a snapshot of everything at the end of
class
i can zoom way out i can do full screen
um
and i can move around a little bit more
easily with this little mini map
tool here so it's again one of those
that you can explore a little bit more
but i've
i've really liked this one it's very
simple but also a little bit more
robust in terms of being um
you know kind of like that canvas feel
which i
like if you know i want to solve a big
problem and i don't have enough retail
space on my screen
i can play a little bit more with some
of these options
so that is awe
app and again there's a paid version or
a free version i'm just using the free
one
all right as you're going to the next
section i just want to give a shout out
you're getting so much love on the chat
people are saying oh i love cami i love
jamboard i love awe so everyone is
sharing their favorite tools and there
are even some additional ones that are
popping up so thank you for sparking a
good conversation oh
fantastic i know and that's the hardest
thing i want to come on here and like
make this as simple as possible for
everybody and say you know
like this is the best one but the
problem is there isn't a best one
and as you can probably see that coming
into the chat there's probably a lot of
conversation about what people
love um and so again i encourage you
to kind of think about what tools your
school's already
using um and maybe there's one that
already resonates with you
but also like getting students on it
more easily if you're already at google
school jamboard's going to be super
simple for you
and for your students if your students
are already using cami that's going to
be super simple to them
you know at this point i don't want to
present too many more tools
um in my classroom because we already
went through
you know kind of some of the pain the
growing pains
of getting on board and that's always
the hardest part now we're in a routine
so um all right so let's go ahead
and dig into using the scratch pad in
khan academy in case you're not using
that
already so i'm going to go ahead right
now
actually let me go back and just tell
you what i'm going to talk about so the
first thing i'm going to talk about
is using it in the student view so this
would be from the assign
tab and this is something that students
also have access to so even if they
don't have
a device you know even if they just need
to use their mouse
they can at least ink up a little bit
as they're thinking through things which
i know is very difficult
but you as a teacher can also use it so
let me show you what i mean
so if i am in that assign tab right here
and then i click on to any of the
assignments
that i have given so let me go ahead
and click into this exercises
and then if i click on student view so
say for example i just want to do like
an
introductory lesson i found some really
nice questions that were in khan academy
i don't want to assign them for students
yet to do on their own i want to just
have a class conversation about it
i can go ahead and pull this up on the
board and then if you
click on here the little whiteboarding
tool
then you'll see that again i get kind of
like my grid paper
which i know we love as math teachers
and
um i can just mark it up so you know i
can
be writing and talking i think there's
real power
in being able to highlight while i'm
talking
being able to write so students can
follow what i'm doing
so i'm saying you know the limit as x
approaches negative two
so now i'm telling everybody you know
pull your eye
to negative two here and
again it's just this quick little visual
of like what's going on so i can pull
that
out for them and then say you know well
what do you see going on from the left
hand side and i can just be drawing
and talking at the same time and then my
students can maybe unmute their mic
chat it out we can talk about it and
then you know just
what's happening from the right hand
side and so we can
discuss it and i think that just makes
for a really nice little discussion
and then we can choose the answer
together so this is again
this could be used for class instruction
or maybe
you assign something and students got
something wrong
you could pull this up um or you could
have them
pull it up on their screen share and ask
them to kind of use these tools to try
and explain what they were thinking so
that you can work through it and coach
them
together so that's a really nice little
tool
in case you haven't used it before and
then
the other way that i wanted to show it
is
after students have responded so say
that
you already gave an assignment everybody
did it for homework now you want to
discuss it in class
you can use a teacher report and again
there is a drawing tool that's available
more on a sidebar in this case so let me
go ahead and go back
and this time i'm going to go ahead and
go into my scores
and let me click on this
so now if we're reviewing all students
here
say that i want to discuss this one
because one person got it wrong
so i can go ahead and pull up the draw
tool right here and then i can just
write on the side so again super simple
i can't draw on the drawing itself in
this case
but uh here was an example that i just
laid out right here for example you know
you might say
what are the three things that you are
looking for here and i could just write
that out and i will
i'm able to write that out because i
have the pen tool
on my wacom tablet if i was using my
mouse i would not be able to write that
out so again that can be a really nice
way
to just talk about things in class so
those are my two favorite ways of using
the whiteboard uh
inc right within khan academy to
bring things out during class or to do
kind of one-on-one
individualized coaching with students
also
so let me pause again and see if there's
any questions coming in before we get
into some
simple screen casting options yeah so
there are so many questions stacy
what i would recommend is why don't we
finish up the content and then save
maybe like 10 15 minutes to really dig
deep into these questions
sounds good to me all right
so again i'm presenting four
options here depending on what you need
for screencasting when it comes to
screencasting there are a lot of options
out there
i'm going to say again if you're a
google school already using google meet
and if you already have the ability to
record not everybody has the ability to
record in google me but if you
have the ability to record in google me
you would see it under your three dots
and you would be able to record
everybody who's using google for
education right now should be able to
record
in google they've made that available
for this year
um so if you're doing that for class
already
you know what you can join a google meet
just you and yourself
and make a nice little screencast
because you will have created a video
right
so you could just join the google meet
all by yourself
you can open up pop open a jamboard for
example
and use the whiteboarding there you go
simple
whiteboard screencast that you can then
it will upload it to your google drive
and then you can give it to students to
go ahead and review
if you are using zoom there's a record
option right in zoom
so you could use the whiteboarding tool
again write in zoom
and you can just record let's keep it
simple um
if you are wanting a chrome extension
there are a couple
you may have used screencastify or loom
um they're both very similar i usually
recommend
loom because it is free for educators um
screencastify has a limit for what you
can do with the free version
so that's why i say loom if you sign up
as an educator not everybody knows about
that there's an educator form that you
can fill out
in which case you get free access to
loom
so that does allow you to do both like
you know the little video
and your screencast at the same time or
you can just do the screencast you get
to choose what you want to do there
screen only screen and cam and you can
record
again you can upload that like to your
google drive you have some
different options there and then lastly
i'm going to present
one paid option which which is camtasia
and i present that because
that's actually what i use to record my
videos that's what i've been using for
um since 2010 actually i use that to
record my videos
and i use that to edit my videos so
that's what i like about that
is that it does have a pretty robust
editor also i can add in like little
uh annotations at the end i can cut
things if i made a mistake
i can do some transitions all of that
good stuff so if you want to invest a
little bit more time and energy
into creating videos and editing them
that's something that you enjoy
i really enjoy editing my videos then i
would recommend looking into a camtasia
license and
make sure that you look for an educator
discount on that because they do have
some educator discounts available
um but that is a paid option and it is
available for both
a pc or a mac
so um i
am going to keep this as simple as
possible again um
one of the easiest ways to start inking
up anything
is to use powerpoint actually and
there is a pen tool available even in
powerpoint online
so i'm going to show you powerpoint
online because this is how i actually
got started with things i just opened up
a powerpoint like i had my powerpoint as
my base
my presentation i had a question
and a lot of blank white space as you
can see here
that's kind of what it looked like
whatever's in red is what i wrote while
i was making the screencast itself
and so when you do this in powerpoint
it's going to save all the annotations
too
so then you have a kind of a final
version
and i usually save my original version
and i um
usually i print out the blank version
for my students so that they can take
notes right on the powerpoint as they're
watching the video
and then you can just go ahead and go to
this drawing tab i'm in powerpoint
online here
and then you go to the drawing tab and
you can choose from a bunch of different
colors and it's nice that it has your
recent colors that are saved right here
you can change the thickness of the pen
tool
um and then you can also use this
different pen tool they're a little bit
different
and have the colors
you have the eraser you have a
highlighter and you can just get started
with making a screencast so again you
could open this up
then use one of screencasting tools we
talked about so you could open up a
google me with you yourself
and press record you can open up a zoom
and record yourself you could also use
screencastify
i use camtasia when i use camtasia
something else i like about that is i
can just like
choose what portion of the screen i want
to record so i would just like select
this portion of the screen with my um
mouse you know so it would like record
just
this portion and then um obviously i was
not using my tablet there so it was very
messy but
uh i would just record that portion and
you wouldn't be able to see any of the
background stuff and so
a lot of the different um tools allow
you to choose just a piece of your
screen instead of recording the entire
screen
so that's something to keep in mind also
loom has that ability i know
so yeah that's the easiest way to
honestly to get started
here powerpoint you use it and it's all
free
if you have powerpoint like the desktop
version
um this is coming to mac i don't think
it's rolled out to everybody i know i'm
in a
program where i get some early releases
of things so it is available
on i am using it on my mac right now
there is a record slideshow it's been
available on a pc
for years if you have powerpoint
downloaded to your computer
you can actually it's a one-stop shop
where you can
create a video um and record your screen
right using powerpoint all in one like
you don't even need a second tool
if that's something that interests you i
have a reference article and also a
video
tutorial that is a windows specific one
but it should be similar for the mac
starting
soon anyway i just wanted to present
that as an option if you're using
powerpoint this is something that
a lot of people aren't aware of again
it's a record slideshow it's right baked
into powerpoint
and you can export it as a mp4 if you
want students to watch it as a video
or you can also give a share link and
that share link is kind of like um
kind of like if i shared these google
slides with you right now
where students can press like the next
button and the next button but it will
play
like a video it's really cool um i
encourage you to check it out if you are
a powerpoint fan if you're not though
i've provided some other options for you
to explore today
so um i did want to show you my actual
process
um and this is a video of my actual
process
these days i use notability on my mac i
paid for that um it wasn't very
expensive but i did purchase notability
which is uh you might be familiar there
is an ios
um application for notability but
there's also a mac application and i
just like it as like
i have it as my digital notebook so
that's what i'm using these days but
honestly
i start off with a powerpoint and you
can replicate the same thing
in powerpoint and i use camtasia to make
my screen recordings then i upload those
for students to watch
so again if you want to see my exact
process that video is available
all right last i think this is like
almost my last question for you
how many flip grid fans do i have here
today
okay so let's cue this one up here um
so we launched the flipgrid poll
and it's looking like a lot of folks
love it maybe more have never used it
before so this is great
great chance to share something powerful
all right so we'll go ahead and share
those results
looks like about 70 have not tried yet
so feel free to share more stacy
okay so i am obviously in the loveit
camp
so flipgrid there's two main things that
you can do in flipgrid one
is that you can record um sorry you can
have students record responses
so it comes in all like a grid of
student replies i'm not gonna focus on
that today
even though that is amazing i use it in
my math class all the time for students
to
explain their math thinking um
and i don't you they don't use any
special whiteboarding or anything like
that
they just use a phone and they hover it
over their piece of paper and they talk
about their math solutions and it's all
posted on one big grid
but what i'm going to talk about today
is more of like the teacher created
um portion here since that is the focus
of our session today
so when you're in flipgrid and this is
free free available for everybody
there is something called the shorts
camera and that is to record a short
video you can record up to 10 minutes in
here
so when i record a short that's gonna be
that's going to
do my whole screen recording and provide
me with a whiteboard
this is super simple all right so what
i'm gonna do here
is i'm gonna go to my effects i know i'm
covering a lot rather quickly so
here we go and you can choose a board
and i can choose a whiteboard what you
can do here is you can also split the
screen
so i could be like in the side of the
video or i can just be like i want only
a whiteboard
and again i have some different types of
paper that i can choose from
and then all i have to do is press the
record button
and now it's actually recording
everything that i do so i can go ahead
and i can open up a pen tool
i can change the color of my pen and i
can get to drawing
so it's very simple very quick i would
just have this one screen
i can always pause if i needed to i
could
reset my screen so i could delete
everything
um you can even in here just to let you
know
there is a record screen feature in here
if you ever want to use
that that um to record your screen
if i didn't already give you enough
options right but
what happens is once you make this let
me go down
it's actually recording everything that
i do so i can go ahead and i can open up
a pen tool all right so if you made a
little mistake
there is a very simple editor here where
you can like double
actually sorry you can double click and
you can you know how you can trim like
the beginning or end of the video you're
able to do that here so i can do that
i can confirm and now
say you forgot to add a clip you can add
more or you want multiple boards you can
do that
another way that i really like to use
this um
is to again just upload a little image
so maybe i have an image of a graph
and then i can just draw on that graph
let me show you how you do that
add more i can go ahead into my effects
and i can use the photo and you can go
ahead and upload a screenshot maybe from
your textbook
or whatever it may be and then you would
be able to just
ink on top of it how you can ink on top
of it again
is you just go into these drawing tools
right here
um and that's really that's really it i
won't show you all the fancy frames that
you can do
which the kids love you know all that
good stuff and then um when you're all
done
you go to next next you can title it
if you want you choose a cover photo
so let's just choose something from the
middle there
there we go confirm great image and
the beauty of this is it's going to
generate a link for me right now
and that's the link that i share with my
students that's it
and now this is a video there's nothing
else to do there's no uploading there's
no downloading
this is a quick whiteboard style video i
guess it's
preparing it still um that's it
see it's available already that's it
and now it's actually so
i'll just stick with that there's so
much more in flipgrid
that you can do but i'll stick with the
simple again if i talked about that too
quickly
and this is the option that you're like
oh this is great simple
let's get started with that one um i
have a little video tutorial on how to
set up your flipgrid
how to get started with that also
um all right so i want to leave plenty
of time for that q a like you said
the last piece which i'm not going to
get in today
but i just wanted to present is um
the the last piece of like how do we
engage our students
during class because this is more like
instructional
stuff that we do um but what do you do
during class time to make sure that all
students are really participating i am
really lucky in that i actually have a
class set
of these wacom tablets so you can see my
students writing with the wacom tablet
i pair this up with paradox and paradox
is a add-on for google slides it's also
available for
um for powerpoint online
and it allows me to see the work of all
different students
in this dashboard view in real time and
this is how i was how i was using it now
where students don't actually have a
tablet
i'm just doing the writing with my
tablet students can still like circle
and answer so i can see
if students are all trying if they're
all responding
um if they're giving it some effort and
then i can
kind of you know write out my reply
um and so the only reason that i bring
this up is that we might have an
opportunity
to bring you all another webinar so we
just wanted to
gauge some interest um to see if you
would be interested
in learning more about like that class
discussion piece learning more
specifically about
how i use paradox we could probably we
could definitely do a whole webinar
on that um so we're gonna do a quick
little um
survey right after the session ends
to see if that is something that you are
interested in
i'm going to just close uh
with this quote i really believe if we
empower students with the resources they
need
and coach them through the process of
using the these tools then students can
take ownership for their learning
and that's where the real magic happens
and so
for me flipping my classroom giving my
students all the resources through the
video
that i prepared them with before they
even walk into class
oh my gosh it's been so transformational
i really didn't even get to talk about
my flipped classroom
kind of how um that's transformed my
teaching
i assign my videos through a tool where
i can see how students are watching the
videos i can embed
questions in the videos i come to class
prepared because i know what students
need and
that has been really transformational
for me but of course the first step is
knowing how to make the videos
so hopefully you got some ideas
today and we'll have plenty of time for
q
a of course i want to share
that code for you all to get
a discount on a wacom product uh
thank you again to wacom for offering
this discount for everybody joining
today
so there are a lot of different products
to explore
um so this link will be dropped into the
chat i see jeremy's already done that
thank you
um and you can explore the different
devices that are available
and you would save 10 with the code
that's available there
all right should we dig into the q a
let's do it and i'm about to give you a
huge shout out stacey because i know you
can't see it
but there is so much love pouring in the
question section saying
best professional development ever i've
learned more in 40 minutes i learned in
like 40 hours of
traditional training so thank you for
being really really actionable
with the kinds of tools that teachers
can use tomorrow um wherever their
students are but let's
let's back up one little bit here
because at the very beginning of the
session michael wants to know
what do these tablets even look like
like what does it look like when a
teacher
uses it if you don't mind holding up
yours just give folks a sense of
how it looks and how it feels okay so
this is the one
um that's really portable this is the
intuos one this is a small
intuo so it's the one that you're seeing
like on my screen share actually right
now it's a small one the one all the way
on the right
and so this is the bluetooth version of
it and so literally you know you just
press the button to turn it on and off
and it's bluetooth enabled
and then when i am using the pen
here um it works exactly
like a huge mouse pad okay so you think
of this as a mouse pad so like this top
left corner
corresponds to the top left of my screen
and this top
the bottom right is like the bottom
right of my screen so wherever i'm
positioning my pen
is where i'm going to be writing on the
screen and so
then i have a pen so it mimics exactly
it's like a giant mouse pad
and i'm able to write with the pen so
that's this style of tablet
i don't see my screen i have to like
look up at my screen
to see where i'm writing so you might be
thinking this is so difficult
here's what i found my students all have
one of these i have a classroom set of
these
um it takes about a month so the first
time they use it they're like what
is this thing how am i supposed to write
with this it does take about a month to
get used to it
to get used to like where you're writing
on the screen you're not dragging it
like a mouse
but you're actually just writing on the
part of the screen but
once you get used to it um and you
can't see but like there's these little
grids on it too so it's easy to like
align and write
straight um it's really helpful to have
those little grid lines i use it a lot
there's also little buttons here if like
you need to click
um and to use it as like a right click
or something so you really can use this
as to navigate um anything that you need
and then um yeah i found you get used to
it in about a month and the writing on
this is
so wonderful like this is used by
artists
um so it's way more than i need as a
math teacher but it feels wonderful it
feels like you're writing
on a piece of paper which is what i love
and then the other one
so what i use more often especially now
since i'm at home
this is the wacom one so it is like okay
let's see much bigger wow
it's 13 inches okay um this one
and this is a pen display style one i
don't have it plugged in right now
because i just didn't want to like
i was afraid with all these people on
that i was going
and my internet would lag or something
when i had too many screens plugged in i
have so many things plugged into my
computer right now
so that's why i don't have it on but
pretty much i keep this thing on plugged
in
all the time into my computer so again
you plug it in with a usb
um into your computer so you plug it in
with the usb you also do have to power
this one into a wall
so that's just something to know but if
you're making videos so you can see
like kind of on my screen here um this
would be the image
it's mirroring your screen it's just
like if you're in a classroom
and you have a projector you know how it
mirrors exactly what's on your screen
that's exactly how this works so it is
like a second display
and you're able to see what you're
writing on so it's
it feels a lot more comfortable i mean i
definitely like my wacom one
what i use more often um it's totally
what i use
for all right so i use it for making my
videos i also use it for grading student
work
so grading student work i actually use
cami students just turn
in a pdf i open it i open up the pdf in
cami and i'm able to hand write
all over it i'm also able to leave video
comments and able to leave
voice comments because we have a paid
subscription to cami
um it's a huge tool if your school
already has it and you haven't explored
it yet
i really recommend checking it out if
you have any questions i have like a
video library on cami itself um
but i use it for that i use it for
lesson planning
um and i use it as like my
daily like notes because i can just mind
map
whatever i want to do and i'm using my
wacom one for that because
i'm plugged in pretty much all the time
right now so
i hope that helps cool that's great and
so you know the next obvious follow-up
question is like hey this looks amazing
but max and i want to know does it work
with my platform with my tools
in general are these compatible with
like macs pcs chromebooks do you know
about that
yeah great question it is compatible
with macs and pcs
um it is not compatible with chromebooks
okay got it and then you were showing so
many of these applications whether it
was jamboard or cami
i assume pretty much anything where
you're on a mac and a pc and you have a
document that you're interacting with
you can use the tablet on it is that
right yeah so
again any of these wacom devices
think of it as like how your if your
mouse currently works with the program
and you're able to currently like press
the pen tool
and draw with a mouse and you know the
unpleasant experience of trying to do
that
then with the wacom you just literally
now have a pen
that you're writing like you're writing
on the screen so
think of it as your mouse pad with a pen
cool
cool that's really helpful and then i
think the elephant in the room question
comes from janetta who says hey i want
one of these so bad
but how do i afford it um have you heard
about teachers using donors choose or
other platforms
to make this more available to their
classrooms yeah i mean
definitely uh people have people have
asked their schools too i know
um a lot of schools are providing them
this year
um so the
again if you wanted to ask for the most
affordable option
the wacom intuos line would be
um the one that i would go for there um
and honestly i would ask for the
bluetooth one because it's only like ten
dollars
more for the bluetooth versus the wired
one and it's something
this is my thing and i've talked to some
teachers about this who want to ask
their school about it
this is not a device that we are using
just now because of remote learning
not at all i mean i've been using these
devices for years and years and years
um this is a device that's going to amp
up
our classroom in all different ways
there's so many ways we can use it we
can use it in class
we can use it before class to um
you know make our classroom led videos
we can also use it post class
to grade student work to make everything
be in one space for students there's
also a lot of benefit
to having all of this saved for students
in their google drive or whatever it may
be because don't forget
if you are making this digital work and
you're saving it for them in a digital
way giving them that digital feedback
now it becomes searchable so that's
something else that's really powerful
so again i've talked a little bit about
cami today but cami
is what i i use and i grade the student
work in that too
and this has ocr optical character
recognition and
that means that anything that's on here
even like
handwritten stuff becomes searchable
super powerful there so um uh that's
what i would say is like this is not
something that we're going to just be
using this year
not to mention so i showed you some of
the newer wacom products right now
but i'm being completely honest here i'm
not just saying this because you know
wacom is here with me
but the class set of tablets that i
showed you like this
class set here you can see that this
tablet looks different than the one i
showed you that's because this is an
older version i got this class set in
2013.
it is still going strong i'm still using
the same class set of of tablets since
2013.
like what other technology are you using
seven years later and it works just as
well as it use
as it worked on day one and that's the i
think the power of these things is
because like it's not tied to an
operating system or anything like that
you just plug it in to your computer um
and you know like worst case scenario
now the usb doesn't plug in and i need a
usbc
adapter like that's really the only
difference but they have true staying
power these things are built to last
um and so it's going to be uh to me an
investment
for if you're making an argument to your
school it's an investment for your
school
very cool well speaking of staying power
i'm seeing so many questions about
battery life
because i think here in 2020 our phones
are dying our ipads are dying we
can't even um get enough chargers to
plug everything in
what's the battery life on these things
i don't know what the battery life is on
the intuos the bluetooth one
it lasts a really long time i mean i i
really don't know i just plug it in
occasionally it's not like it's not
gonna run out during my class
day um it also doesn't stay on the whole
time
so i don't worry about that the wacom
one
has to be plugged into the wall all the
time so
there's that and then the class set that
i have is the one where
um they plug it in so i've never run
into that before because
it doesn't there's no battery so i don't
i don't know
the exact specs on how long the battery
lasts
very cool um i see a lot of questions
coming in
about like using this for specific use
cases i know you're a math teacher
but um you know if you were imagining a
teacher especially in a special special
education environment
who want to use it to really energize
their students during this very
difficult time
are there any tips you might recommend
to really use this to engage and harness
the creativity of their students
yeah um okay so i guess the first thing
that i really
believe in i really do believe in the
power of handwriting
both for students and for us as teachers
so for example when i make my flipped
classroom videos i'm always writing as
i'm talking
um i've seen some people they feel like
their videos look a little bit more
professional when they write it all out
ahead of time because their handwriting
looks neater they're you know like
they're kind of scripting it they're
able to write and then
talk for me students follow
as i'm writing so i like to write
and talk because they're doing the same
and i want them to be taking notes
and they're able to kind of see how i'm
working through the flow of that problem
so i think there's huge power in being
able to write
and talk so um like to me
a lot of times i think that making a
lesson
where i kind of have maybe even i'm just
using the jamboard
very simply and i have a little bit of
bullet points but then i have
i'm writing as i'm talking i'm writing
out some bullet points there
i think it's more engaging because
students are seeing something on the
screen
versus just the flat text
do you know what i mean um and even if
you just like draw
little images as you're going uh that
can be really powerful
too so um i think it's auto sketch
that it's like is that what it's called
i really like that
because auto draw that's what it's
called obviously it's saved in my thing
because like you can be sketching as
you're doing
class i don't use in my math class but
it recognizes what you're doing
so like if i start drawing something
um it will recognize it so
i can have terrible drawing and be like
oh yeah i was trying to draw
a van and so you know again so it can
just be like the power
of having some visuals so students can
see
um that and maybe you could allow them
to you know you could pass a tablet
around
and allow them to sketch note i think
that's something else that can be really
powerful having students
summarize um what they're learning
through
sketches and little um annotations so
again you could have them here
drawing and then also they can use just
the regular draw tool here and they can
actually hand write there that wouldn't
be auto recognized this magical one
is the one that's going to auto
recognize whatever you're writing
so uh yeah that could be just a simple
really powerful tool yeah i think that's
powerful for every student like
especially in this moment when we're all
apart
to bring more visuals more sort of
eye-catching moments into our uh
teaching is so powerful
um what about for younger students again
i know that you teach older students in
your day job
but have you heard about teachers using
this successfully with younger students
especially if you're giving them the
tablets and asking them to
input their own handwriting yeah um
so i am lucky i work at a k-12 school so
i get to see
the younger kids in our lower school
grades um
all of our students are actually using
seesaw so if your school's using seesaw
it's already built in there that they're
able to draw on anything they're able to
actually draw and record at the same
time
so they can talk out their math thinking
or whatever thinking that they
are doing and if you're able to pass out
the tablet then they can really practice
the writing also
um which can be you know super powerful
for our youngest students they do um i
will say that they do
very well with just using a mouse um and
usually what they're drawing is
rather simple so maybe they're drawing
some shapes or you're trying to help
them
like learn about counting and that's one
of the most difficult things right now
um i also have a niece that's six years
old and
and she's also using seesaw and
sometimes we get on the video and we do
it together and it's like
she's trying to add the numbers and
she's doing really well with it but
sometimes she just needs
those visuals so we're able to either
draw them out
sometimes i i tell my sister to go get
her some crackers so that she can
she can pull those up too uh and
but you know you could even take a
picture of some of those pull them into
seesaw or whatever it is and then use
the pen to cross
things out to i think that's the power
like
starting to verbalize your thinking
process so whether that's a student
or you as the teacher who has a device
and you're able to really make it
visual to students what's going on
and again not just like a powerpoint
presentation with some fancy animations
i personally just find this harder to
follow i need to see the writing the
flow
um i also need to be doing the writing
um that to me like i cannot
i don't know about other math teachers i
cannot like type a math solution
i like when i'm doing my solutions i
have to hand write it totally maybe i'll
type it up afterwards but
i can't think like that there's
something about the like the sketching
the doodling that actually unlocks your
brain in a powerful way
oh yeah i also don't think completely
linearly
i think that's it too like with all
these whiteboarding apps we can be
writing in different spaces on the
screen and it doesn't have to be
so linear so we really can map
information together and help our
students understand how all this stuff
webs together
i think that's why i liked the ah app
that i showed you too because you can
have like
you can be writing here and here and
here and here and then you can
zoom out and see that web all come
together make those connections
very cool well speaking of making
connections you've connected so many
educators across the country tonight
stacy
um to each other to awesome
opportunities in their classrooms
so i have to thank you so much on behalf
of this audience
um that being said any final words of
wisdom as folks get ready for the end of
the year and the start of a new one
oh my gosh right um i
first i just want to say thank you to
everybody who is on this call today
because i know
how much everybody's already doing right
now and then taking the time out this
evening
to just further grow as an educator i
mean
this is why i love teachers when i first
started teaching i was like i know i'm
in the right profession as soon as i saw
how generous educators are
and just like that love of learning so i
really appreciate you being here
um and everything that you know you all
are doing right now
in the classroom and trying to make it
all work
if i can help in any way please do reach
out
um again my information is here um
contact information is on my blog also
if you are on twitter i'm very active on
twitter and
you can go ahead and leave me a message
and i will definitely respond back to
you
if you click on any of the videos that i
shared today again they're also in the
pdf that you can take home later
if you watch some of those videos that i
have on youtube and you
um have a question please just put it in
the comments on youtube
i definitely get to all of my youtube
comments so um that's sometimes the
easiest way
you know you're watching and you're like
well what do i do here
um just let me know because as i said
i just wish that i could have come to
this today and said like these are the
three apps that you need
um but that wouldn't be me being real um
me being real
is trying to find what you're doing at
your school already and
offering a solution that's going to work
well for you and your students even
though
i might have a favorite one that might
not be what's best for
you and your setting so i hope that the
variety of tools kind of
got you thinking and then you will be
able to click
on one of them zone in on that and
as you do and as questions come up
please do reach out
um and i'll do my best to answer
cool thank you so much stacey and thank
you again to everyone for joining
tonight
just another quick recap you will get an
email with a recording of the session as
well as stacy's pdf
you'll get a link to that generous
discount offered by wacom
and everyone who joined live will
automatically be entered
into a drawing for one of five wacom
tablets and we'll notify those winners
shortly
in the meantime thank you as stacy said
for all that you do
we wish you a tremendous conclusion to
the year and a great start to 2021
and we can't wait to see all the
incredible things you do next based on
some of these awesome tips thank you so
much stacey and goodnight everyone
thank you bye
you